بقى كيف تمدح التمويلات يعني ما هي اليه
منح هذه التمويلات للشركات الناشئه ما هي
المعايير المحدده لذلك
بالنسبه للتمويل يعتقد انه يعني كل صندوق
تمويل
بيتخصص في مرحله معينه من التمويل بصندوق
يتخصص في مجال معين من من الصناعه التي
يتم التركيز عليها فنجد بعض الصناديق
التمويليه تتركز في مناطق جرى في جغرافيه
معينه بعض الصناديق تتركز في مراحل معينه
من المشاريع ما نسميها بالمرحله قبل
البذره او البريسيد مراحل البذره سيد او
مراحل متاخره من من نمو المشروع وكذلك
يعني نجد صناديق تمويليه تتخصص كذلك في
صناعات معينه صناديق تتركز في التقنيه
الماليه صناديق تتركز في التقنيه الحيويه
صناديق تتركز في الاي اي وغيرها من
الصناعات وكذلك الصناديق
لا تركز على التقنيه يعني الاستثمارات
يعني ممكن حصرها باستثمارات في مجال
التقنيه واستثمارات خارج مجال التقنيه
فالحديث اعتقد انه حيكون في في مجال
التقنيه بشكل عام فهذا هذا هذا هذا المحدد
الاول اللي هو
مجال اختصاص الصندوق للاستثمار
زي مثل ما ذكرنا انه كل صندوق له تركيز
على مجال معين صحيح بس هل اصبحت الامور
اسهل لتمويل الشركات الناشئه المتعلقه
بالتكنولوجيا كلنا نتذكر كيف كانت قصه
انشاء الفيسبوك كم كم يعني
تعب مؤسسوه من اجل الحصول على تمويلات
ماليه هل بعد النجاح وبعد هذا التقدم
التكنولوجي اصبحت الافكار المتعلقه
بالتكنولوجيا
قابله اكثر للفهم من اجل التمويل بكل
تاكيد رحله رياده الاعمال تعتبر رحله شاقه
وليست بالسهله
فرحله رائد الاعمال تبدا من
اقتناع المحيط
القريب من من صاحب الفكره او رائد الاعمال
او رائد الاعمال
بتبني مشروعه ومن ثم دعمه
استثماريا لو لو نذكر مراحل الاستثمار من
الاساس تتم عن طريق الاهل والاصدقاء
بعدها تنتقل للاينجل او المستثمرين
الملائكين بعدها تنتقل الى مراحل اخرى من
من من حيث الاستثمار عن طريق صناديق
الاستثمار الجري
فبالتاكيد حتى في الاسواق الناضجه رحله
رحله رائد الاعمال تعتبر رحله شاقه مثلها
مثل رحله رائد الاعمال في البلدان العربيه
في البلدان
التي يعني المنظومه تعتبر وصلت الى مرحله
مرحله النضج الخيارات تعتبر اكثر
لرائد الاعمال او رائد الاعمال البحث عن
الممولين وكذلك فهم الممولين لنوع
المخاطره التي يعني هم بصدد اخذها في هذا
النوع من الشركات فهي شركات تعتبر عاليه
المخاطر ولما نقول عاليه المخاطر المخاطر
بمعنى انه المستثمر ممكن ان يفقد كامل راس
ماله في عندما يستثمر في فرصه معينه